I recently got my hands on the upcoming
third installment of The Witcher series
The Wild Hunt and I can safely say that
if like me you enjoyed its predecessor
assassins of Kings this latest offering
plays vastly the same only set free in a
massive and detailed open-world which is
good news for more detailed look and
chat about what we actually played want
to go check out this other video I made
with mark but what if you've never
played a Witcher game before how'd you
know if CD Projekt Reds latest offering
is your cup of need well I have one
question for you do you like Game of
Thrones now stay with me you see it
dawned on me while playing that these
two fantasy worlds are extremely similar
in many important ways and I'm talking
way beyond superficial things like
swords British accents and beards what's
wrong with my beard nothing girl your
beard is lovely now ish I listen to my
eleven reasons why The Witcher 3 might
be the closest thing we're ever going to
get to a truly great Game of Thrones
RPG
don't be fooled by the beautiful and
varied environments that greet you in
The Witcher 3 this world is ugly brutal
and dangerous death prejudice and
betrayal are every bit as common as the
peasant soldiers and monsters they call
at home it is such a savage place in
fact that it can be hard to imagine how
anyone beyond the rich and fortunate can
eke out a living here remind you of
anywhere
this gritty flavor is echoed in the
tales told in The Witcher Universe now
this point we know very little about the
story of three but based on its heritage
it's clear that storytelling is valued
as highly as gameplay by the folks CD
Projekt RED this manifests in the game
with complex narratives and detailed
characterization at its core whether
this is executed as well as in George RR
Martin's offering is up for debate but
if you like experiences which are as
much about story as they are about
actual fighting then my guess is The
Witcher 3 will likely not disappoint
as with Game of Thrones a shrewd
politician in the world of The Witcher
can be as deadly as the most heavily
armored foe though you play mostly as
Geralt the infamous silver-haired
Witcher who doesn't engage directly in
politics through him your actions do
make an impact on the political
landscape this was certainly the case in
The Witcher 2 anyway and based on the
initial sequence I got my hands on we
can expect much more of this to come in
the Wild Hunt
morale matters are rarely black and
white in both Game of Thrones and The
Witcher as the witcher geralt you are
frequently given decisions with a moral
component these are not labored or even
labelled as in some RPGs they're more
subtle do you reject payment for helping
someone who you now suspect to be a liar
and possibly a murderer or do you take
that coin and upgrade your weapons to
aid in the killing of a menacing Griffon
for the greater good of the town
morality in this game you see is all
shades of gray and speaking of shades of
gray like George RR Martin's epic tale
there are as many as sexy encounter to
be had in The Witcher 3 if the first
hours are anything to go by literally
the opening cutscene is both abstract
and but tacular this is not mere sex
position however according to the
developers more of a storytelling device
to reveal the complex relationships
between the key characters and their
butts if you enjoy all the gore in Game
of Thrones then The Witcher 3 should
certainly satisfy your bloodlust the
trailers have hinted at this mature
total ready
and by hinted I mean this crow exploring
at the back of a man's head
Wow this Gore factor is present in game
too frequently Garrett's killing slice
will lop off an arm a head or even a
wing the client of Steel on steel is a
familiar sound in The Witcher 3 and like
Game of Thrones
the fighting doesn't stand on pomp and
ceremony it's brutal fast and deadly
less fancy swashbuckling are more nasty
squash buckling your limbs did that work
close enough onwards combat isn't only
about weapons magic too exists in the
world of The Witcher as Geralt you can
cast signs to aid you in battle
these range from great balls of fire to
protective shields however if you're
drawn to the world of Westeros because
of its subtle inclusion of magic then
don't let this put you off The Witcher
magic is woven into the game setting
more of a strange strand of the fabric
of life than an OTT power that everyone
wields giants dragons and White Walkers
it's fair to say the game of Thrones is
fond of monsters and if deadly mythical
creatures is your bag then once again
The Witcher will deliver as a Witcher
it's Geralt job to have these jerks good
thing too as the world is crawling with
them granted it's not quite a dragon but
hey this Gryphon is still pretty
impressive
ah
Daenerys she used to be my favorite you
know at the beginning and then her story
just went a bit mad this is just me
anyway she's a big deal in Game of
Thrones arguably the main character a
Targaryen princess with white blond hair
some call her mother of dragons the
chosen one way way way way
that's not Danny that's ciri she is both
Geralt sward and a Witcher in training
she was also a second playable character
in The Witcher 3 set to be a crucial
piece in the game's main storyline oh
yeah Charles dance is actually in them
both and his voice is just the best have
a listen I shall give her what she
deserves
oh and one more special bonus for you
guys it appears I'm not the first person
to notice this similarity when playing
the game traveling the wilds I overheard
two peasants discussing a horrific event
that happened recently something they
called the red funeral the less said
about that the better
anyway let me know if you're excited for
The Witcher 3 and if you can spot any
other similarities between these two
fantasy realms leave me a comment or hit
me up on Twitter and come back to
Gainesville comm for more on the Witcher
3
you